Oh God.
It's so..
It's so fucking cold.
Fuchi-desu.
This is the last fucking time I'm trusting Tinder pictures.
Let's start off with the Junji Ito Collection since I've
never been a fan of horror anime
because, well, they've never been that...
..scary.
But as a fan of Junji Ito's very unsettling horror that worms its way into your psyche,.
I've always thought that a good adaptation of his work was the last bastion of hope for horror anime.
[Very convincing meow]
I think I've lost all hope now.
All right, the second episode was a lot better.
But I think the real problem lies in that his terrifying art just falls a bit flat in this adaptation--
If it can even be captured at all.
So instead, let's watch this cute little show about babysitters!
Baby scissors?
Baby shitters.
At least, I think these are babies are not adorably reanimated Nenodroids.
And really, what can I say.
Japan is back at it again trying to get their population to breed with a show
about babies being absolutely adorable little bastards.
Yeah, fuck him up. Fuck, fuckin' get 'im. Fuck him up.
You know, it's shows like this that remind me that babies can actually be really cute.
When there's not five of them sitting next to you on a 13 hour flight every time apparently.
*in the background*
Wait, Makoto Shinkai, is that you? :D
And here we see a tech demo of a scene rendered in real time running on the new KyoAni engine.
Now, let's compare this to shots from the real-life engine
and as you can see...
Real life is looking pretty ugly right now.
Do we have any questions?
Yeah, uh, excuse me, this is a great tech demo but, uh,
can we expect the plot or characters to be patched in anytime soon?
Someone...
someone get this guy out.
Yeah, I'm not really feeling this so far.
I mean it's one of the most beautiful things
I've ever seen but at the moment
It's just very pretty looking cardboard.
Violet at the beginning is bland enough to dilute the taste of sandpaper.
And nothing is grabbing me about the plot.
The backstory seems way more interesting than what's going on.
Just ask them to read the letter back to you
and stop trying to play hard to get
you stupid, thirsty, cock teasing, dick mongerer.
But I guess I'll still be watching to see if things do pick up in the kuudere adventures of Fullmetal Saber.
See, the problem of watching a show right after Violet Evergarden
is that my mind is now wired to think that everything looks absolutely awful by comparison.
So hold on, I'm just gonna have to bleach my eyes back to normal.
[Griffith did nothing wrong]
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
Okay, I think that should do the trick.
Haha, Saber, what are you doing here again?
Why have you been downgraded to 360p?
God, look at this Saber ripoff.
Jesus, they're not even trying anymore.
I mean, this just looks like Fate.
It IS Fate.
It's another Fate, guys.
It's...
another fucking Fate, guys.
You know, as happy as I am that we can add another Fate to the small list that already exists.
Is it even possible to keep track of where everything fits?
But you know what?
I'm just...
I'm just gonna let this go.
It's just one more Fate show to add to the collection this seaso--
NO!
WHY?!
Why is there a Fate show about Shiro cooking food?
Where does this fit in the timeline!?
Oh God!
It's by fucking ufotable too!
Why U-Fo-Table?!
Don't you have Heaven's Feel to be working on?
This is not what we meant when we said we wanted more Type-Moon from you!
Now this.
This I can get behind though.
I don't know why I enjoyed Overlord season one as much as I did,
being an Isekai about a guy trapped in a video game
and yes, I did get bored halfway through saying that sentence.
But being able to watch a ridiculously overpowered villain trying to take over the world was just a nice popcorn entertainment
I needed just before I got bored of the concept
so I am very much looking forward to season 2.
I'm also obligated to say that Book Walker are doing an Overlord giveaway now
and you can win this Nenodroid by buying any of the Overlord light novels and using COUPON CODE: GIGGUK. Details at the end.
And now, coming from the guy who skips openings comes an opening I will not skip because holy shit.
This track is a fucking tune.
Are you listening to this right now?
Oh, and the show has something to do with stopping time in a giant stand or something.
But can we just jam to this opening a bit more?
How about I just shut up and let it play?
Yo Sydney, what's that?
I..
It's my fucking jam!
And now for my secret technique.
[Ear Rape]
You...
are already gay.
Nani?!
Citrus should be an essential part of everyone's diet.
Studies have shown that consuming the right amount of citrus can give you health benefits such as:
A healthy heart,
Reduced risk to cancer,
Healthy skin,
A raging boner.
Common types of citrus fruits that are healthy for you can include:
Oranges,
Lemons,
Incest,
Lesbian incest,
Lesbian sexual assault sister incest
And...
Grapefruit.
Is this it?
Is this the next evolution in the trash genre.
I mean, we've had yuris.
We've had imoutos.
But now get ready for...
[EXPLOSION]
YURIMOUTO
No, this is going even further.
Finally after all these years.
We have perfected the forbidden formula:
Yuri,
Incest,
NTR,
Rape.
By your powers combined, I am Captain
SMUT!
Guys, I-I think I'm starting to realize this isn't an anime about oranges.
*in the background*
Hoho, Makoto Shinkai! Is that you? :D
So we got the dream daddy anime adaptation we never asked for with a neck to challenge "Welcome to the Ballroom's" crown
And a lot could have gone wrong in a plot about a schoolgirl crushing on a man double her age
But I actually really liked her.
She was weird, but adorably weird, and you know what?
Right now, I'm actually just rooting for her to shoot for her dreams and hopefully make it.
*in the background*
At least...
at least you tried.
You know, I honestly think that "Boss Baby" totally deserves the Oscar nomination over "A Silent Voice"
It's just fair, you know, for an award like this.
Oh, did you hear?
They're doing the Anime Awards again this year?
I do you hope my favorite wins again.
Like when I voted for Yuri on Ice.
[Rightfully smacked]
And here it comes,
It's...it's the edge of the season.
I mean, what is this even?
Kemono friends gone wild?
[Roll Credits]
Hmmmmm...
Eh
You know what, let's just clear our palate with a nice inoffensive anime about shogi.
Uh oh,
I don't think I like where this is going.
Oh for fuck-
I was just trying to watch an anime about shogi.
That's the thing about anime lolis:
I get older and they...
they just keep getting fucking younger, don't they?
Jesus Christ, why the fuck do you keep doing this, anime?
[Moving on chuckle]
Well, thanks Madhouse for reminding us about "No Game No Life"
You know, just in time for you to never give us season 2.
Okay, I got to be honest.
You know that feeling when you think you could be watching something that turns out really special?
This series was it for me.
It's rare that I find a show that captures the youthful
optimism, camaraderie and adolescent spirit
as well as this does.
Every episode is brimming with energy.
The casts has some of the best chemistry
I've ever seen and it's incredibly inspiring for anyone
who's ever wanted to undertake an adventure in their lives,
but never had the courage to.
Really capturing that free-spirited journey.
I have really high hopes for this.
Not only because there are a few phrases that can get me going as much as:
(this is a Madhouse original anime)
But every episode thus far has hit all the right points with absolute ease.
Of course, with high school girls going to the
desolate, harsh environment Antarctica is.
I see absolutely no issue with a bunch of young children
exploring an uninhabited and dangerous world by themselves--
'Ey, hold on a second!
*in the background*
Hehe-hey! Makoto Shinkai! Is that you? :D
All right, it's time for "Pop Team Epic".
I don't really know what to expect,
but let's see what this is about.
[Ode to Joy intensifies]
What?
Oh hey, it's a show about ramen.
I wonder what this is gonna be like.
[Shluuuurrppp]
[More needlessly erotic shlurps]
What?
Namae, kimi no namae wa?
*in the background*
Haha-hey, Makoto Shinkai! Is that you? :D
But hey look it's an older man groping a younger woman in the workplace.
Well, this is sure to go down well in 2018.
Oh my god guys,
I think...
I think I found her.
It's girl of the season.
I think...
I think I'm gonna claim her.
She's mine.
Hey!
[Waifu tournament arc noises]
Get off me, I found her first.
So this is the newest collaboration between A-1 pictures and Studio Trigger.
Which you can really tell because it looks like they've taken Trigger's style and sanded off all the edges.
And I did want to talk about mecha designs.
Which are, of course, very "Star Driver"-esque
And how the show feels like it's sorely missing a Hiroyuki Sawano score.
I mean I can't be the only one who's watching these scenes and waiting for a Sawano drop.
But for now, I have something more important to say
and this is for all of us.
Since the beginning of mankind, we have strived to innovate.
From the first tools that separated us from the animals
to the technology that allows us to defy God.
We always push forward.
We built faster.
We built bigger.
We built smarter.
Conquered our known world.
Explored the deepest oceans.
Shot for the stars.
Our limits were only those in our imaginations
as we continue to push what we thought would never be possible.
Science fiction became science fact.
Nothing was impossible if we could dream it
and
we
did.
Which is why today,
I am proud to present the crowning achievement
our species has met thus far.
We at THOTgineering are proud to present:
Butt control!
A revolutionary control system where you can pilot a mech by grabbing a girl's butt.
Hey guys, hope you enjoyed the video!
A lot of the source material for the shows I just talked about
are available on Book Walker.
Including "Overlord"
As of right now, they are doing a giveaway for Overlord stuff.
You can win this Nendroid set or some signboards by purchasing
any of the light novels or manga.
Use COUPON CODE: GIGGUK for a discount which will
mean you'd be spending less than $2 to enter.
This ends in two weeks on February 12th,
so enter while you can.
Anyway, that's it for me.
I'm gonna be off to Japan once again next week.
So until then,
I've been Gigguk
and I will see you all next time.